[Musique]
claudine des ménages l'entreprise
qu'elle a choisi lui envoie une
estimation du prix de son déménagement
500 dollars basée sur le nombre de
pièces et les informations qu'elle a
donnée mais jour j déménageur paraissent
surpris ils prétendent que claudine a
beaucoup de meubles dans son cinq et
demi le travail dure deux heures de plus
que prévu les déménageurs lui annonce
que la facture est passée de 500 à 750
dollars payables avant le déchargement
claudine refuse de payer les déménageurs
menace alors de conserver ses meubles
ont-ils le droit oui c'est ce qu'on
appelle le droit de rétention
mais est ce vraiment claudine qui attend
de meubles ou les déménageurs qui
abusent de ce droit comme claudine ne
s'entend pas avec eux elle doit payer
puis les poursuivre ou petites créances
le fin mot de l'histoire
les déménageurs mal intentionnés peuvent
faire du kidnapping
choisissez les biens pour éviter le
camping